ready all right this is the 26th
amendments to the Constitution section 1
the right of citizens of the United
States who are 18 years of age or older
to vote shall not be denied or abridged
by the United States or by any State on
account of age the Congress shall have
power to enforce this article by
appropriate legislation I think that's
really great and this was only passed in
1971 1971 I was 15 years old in 1971 I
was close to that age I
I hope it's it's an empowerment I was
disappointed I must say in the last
election whichever person you may choose
to be your elected official I think
that's a societal thing I think we've
devalued the the honor and privilege of
voting and we've become complacent and
maybe a bit cynical about our place and
rights as citizens and our duties and
responsibilities and I think we need to
reinforce that to realize we're damn
lucky to be able to be citizens of a
country that that allows free and
independent when working at its best
free and independent elections and we
can't take that lightly and I hope that
we realize just how important it is and
support the privilege to to be able to
say you voted in election and I hope you
do thank you
you
[Music]